hello everyone and welcome to a really
incredible game from a really incredible
match of the quarterfinals of the speed
Chess Championship it is Wesley so
versus alireza fieruja and this is the
Armageddon game and it was as I
understand the longest game so far of
the speed the longest match so far of
the speeches Championship uh here you
can see all the scores uh through
different time formats so first uh
Wesley started with a with an incredible
seven to two in the five plus one
section which is very hard to uh catch
up uh two as it's a five five point
difference and then alireza retaliated
in the three plus one section with the
same result seven wins at the Wesley's
two wins and the score was equal so one
could draw the conclusion that maybe as
the time format gets lower alireza gets
stronger but no uh when it came to
Bullet the OnePlus One section uh the
result was four and a half to four and a
half so again the match was equal they
went into tie breaks and in the tie
breaks four games were played and the
score was two uh two already visa and 2
for Wesley so so 15 and a half each and
now it's time for Armageddon uh Wesley
got the white pieces and that means that
Wesley gets the full five minutes
whereas alireza he gets three minutes
and 40 seconds I think it's three
minutes and 39 seconds to be exact so as
usual in Armageddon Wesley has to win in
order to win the match and dalireza is
uh more than happy with a draw so let's
see what Wesley goes for he started with
quanta E4 uh we have Pawn to E5 Knight
F3 Knight to C6 and now Bishop to C4
going for the Italian game Knight to F6
the two nice defense and now Pawn to D3
so the standard modern Bishop's opening
Bishop to C5 Castles by both of them and
now Pawn to A4 grabbing more space on
the queen side uh we have Pawn to D6 and
now uh C well Bishop to G5 can be played
C3 is the most common move here
sometimes some other moves are played
but very rarely uh but the move uh
Wesley played is Bishop to E3 and it has
never been played before so as of seven
we have a completely new game
uh so okay how can always uh deal with
this uh he can play something like A6 to
make room for the bishop he can capture
on E3 or he can try and keep the tension
with Bishop to B6 uh so that's what he
did and now Wesley uh played Knight beat
D2 with Pawn to H6 and C3 both of them
have to play really fast because in uh
Armageddon there is no increment so we
have Knight to G4 challenging the bishop
Here and Now Wesley has to trade
otherwise Knight captures Bishop will
occur so Bishop captures sunny on B6 a
cap for some B6 uh and now Wesley
strikes in the center with the D4 so the
Indie is a jungle piano type positions
it's very very hard to to look for
Advantage but on the other hand if you
play one move that looks okay but is not
uh your entire position just collapses
and uh okay uh he does have the uh sort
of a ruined Pawn structure here on the
queen side but he does have the
semi-open file for his Rook so Rook to
E8 now adding another Defender to E5 and
The Rook to E1 we have knighted back to
F6 bioled as a and now Bishop to B5 here
uh the question is can you can you play
B4 B4 of course is a move you always
want to play but if you play it a bit
too early you might run into e captures
on D4 and now okay how do you deal with
this you have to play uh Queen to B3
first you have to put pressure on F7 and
only after uh alireza deals with this
let's say captures and captures you're
gonna recapture on D4 and now okay you
have this very nice position you're
threatening D5 probably rule goes back
to E8 and uh you continue with having A4
and B for uh played but uh Wesley wants
to keep the tension he doesn't want to
do any unnecessary trades even of Pawns
and Bishop to D7 now the thread of
course is D5 and you will blunder
material here so you have to defend
Bishop to D7 now comes Pawn to H3 and
now Knight to E7 all it is offers a
trade of Bishops as the more he trades
down the easier it will be to draw the
game uh Bishop captures Knight captures
and now Knight to F1 Wesley's Knight is
looking for some squares on E3 and G3 in
the future you are of course looking at
the F5 Square so Knights the G6 we have
Knight to G3 and Knight to F6 very nice
opposition of the knights uh Queen to C2
uh and now Queen to D7 now the queen uh
is very strong here the Rooks are
connected and you are putting pressure
on that A4 Pawn so Wesley one thing he
cannot do is move the queen uh so here
Wesley plays Pawn to C4 with ideas of
maybe advancing even further in the
center with D5 and all it is I could
play something like Knight to F4 but he
goes for Knight to H7 now the Knight can
come to G5 the Knight can come to f8 all
depends on what Wesley plays we have
Queen to D2 and here comes the first
mistake of the game when I was watching
this I wasn't sure if this was actually
a mistake because uh well it's uh it's
Wesley so and the queen is being
re-maneuvered over to the king side but
he does blunder the A4 pawn and later
after the game he admitted that he has
overlooked this so uh alvareza of course
grabbed it and now not an automatic
recapture First Pawn to B3 at least get
something for your sacrifice material
now you have a very nice Center here
Rook to A6 not going for trades and now
the captures an E5 of course Pawn cannot
capture as the queen on D7 would hang
but Knight can capture and now we have
knighted the D4 now this Knight has the
option of going to F5 as well this
Knight can come to H5 and you can put
some pressure on Black's position so
Knight back to F6 and now Rook 8 to D1
uh Knights the G6 by alireza and now we
have Knight D to F5 the Knight now
finally lands and you do have some
threads here of maybe Knight captures on
G7 uh not right away but even if you
play something like let's say Rook
rookie to A8 and uh you allow Knight
captures and G7 it's still not crushing
because after King captures a new for
example go Knight to F5 with check King
to G8 and queen captures on H6 you do
not get to Checkmate black because
there's 98 now the checkmating square is
defended and after H4 preparing H5 you
can even play Queen to E6
so H5 let's say at night goes back uh to
f8 and the position uh still holds uh so
yeah you have to be very careful but uh
yeah you know if you play a really silly
move and allow this then it should work
however Rook the A5 was played uh
alireza says all right even if you
sacrifice a knight then when the other
night lands I'm just gonna give up The
Rook for the night so here we have Pawn
to F4 B4 can also be played uh but I
mean B4 can be played in any position so
Pawn to F4 yeah preparing to further
expand now if you sacrifice you can even
start with some F5 E5 ideas and here we
have Queen to C6 both of them are
playing very fast and the situation on
the clock is two and a half minutes for
Wesley and something something close to
one and a half minutes for alireza so
he's still down one minute on the clock
and uh I have to remind you there is no
increment here now uh uh instead of this
queen to C6 move you might be thinking
why not just capture this and then the
knight uh here is left defenseless if
you recapture with the Knight point is
that now Wesley has Knight captures on
H6 it comes with checks so uh you would
ruin the pawn structure and only then
recapture on e4 so that's why after F4
uh Queen to C6 was played by alireza
with King to H2 and now finally Knight
captures on e4 and now of course the
queen is being attacked so you could
move it to B2 uh to threaten Checkmate
uh but Wesley plays Queen to D for he
threatens Checkmate here and alireza
just brings the Knight back so he won
back uh uh the pawn not one back he's
now up two pawns uh and the Wesley has
to create something out of nothing
basically and Knight captures on G7
still doesn't work if you play Knight
captures on G7 now there's the
incredible Rook to A2 that's one of the
reasons also while there is a put the
queen on C6 now Checkmate is being
threatened and there's no good way to
handle this uh if you just play
something like this then you just trade
you don't really care you trade
everything captures captures captures
and then at the only at the end of the
line you will capture on G7 and you will
be up a full night so after Knight you
have six Rook captures 98 was played and
now everything is perfectly fine if
alireza captures with the Knight you
capture with the Knight and you defend
Checkmate here however after Rook
captures 98 alireza played Queen capture
Sunny 8 and remember what we just
discussed what was the queen doing on C6
keeping that in mind uh feel free to
pause the video and win the game for
Wesley while I give you a couple of
seconds
[Music]
foreign for those of you who were able
to do it congratulations on finding this
incredible line and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is night
captures on G7 but Knight captures and
G7 alone will not do it so
congratulations if you found it but you
also have to see the second move of the
variation uh as uh now you have to
capture it if you don't capture then
just Queen captures on F6 and you get
destroyed so King captures and now comes
the move that actually wins the game not
Knight captures on G7 that's only you
know starting the line but the move is
of course Pawn to B4 and this incredible
move now uh completely cuts off The Rook
from the fifth Rank and once The Rook
leaves the fifth rank then of course
Knight is coming to F5 or H5 so you have
to put it something Rook today it was
played but now you don't have the queen
here so Rook A2 does not come with Tempo
and now comes Knight to F5 check and it
you could easily ruin your Masterpiece
here because if Knight to H5 check which
seems like it should also be winning is
just not because after King to f8 and
queen captures an F6 you can play Rook
characters in G2 check that's the
problem and after King captures there's
Queen T to check and you have enough
checks and enough squares to ensure a
Perpetual King can come to G3 Queen E3
check even if King comes to G3 you just
repeat uh there's no of course you uh
now you have to go back and it's a
repetition because if you go to F5 then
Knight stage for check and your King has
no squares you're gonna have to capture
with the queen and then Queen to E6 is
Checkmate so that's uh a huge problem
right there so instead after Rook to A2
uh Wesley finds the correct continuation
and that is Knight to F5 with check and
now where do you go to uh alvareza
played King to f8 the only real try here
is King to H7 but it just looks so weird
putting your king here point is that
after King to H7 and queen captures and
F6 you have Queen to G8 and now you uh
still uh are threatening some tricky
moves here with some Rook captures on G2
to give you an example if white plays a
rook D1 of course you wanna get that uh
Rook up the board to go for some
uh a rock lift cell uh like Rook to Y8
will you know for Force just a win the
queen has no squares and then you're
gonna Checkmate the black king uh now
Rook captures and G2 check is actually a
great move if King captures You're Gonna
Play Knight to the H for check now
nicely connect with the Knight here and
once the king moves you will now go for
a king hunt Queen to G2 checking if
three Queen captures with check will
connect nicely with the Knight you're
gonna win the Knight and you're still
gonna try to defend this white is still
much better maybe even close to winning
but you have a chance of course
defending with the King doesn't work
because you just get checkmated Queen F3
checking to D4 C5 check and once the
pawn is recaptured it will be Checkmate
so that's uh the the problem here after
Knight to F5 check only real tracking to
H7 but alireza play King to fa remember
uh we uh we are talking seconds on the
clock here for all areas or without
increment uh Queen characters on F6 uh
now threatening Checkmate as the Knight
also covers the E7 Square so Queen to E2
freeing up the square for the king and
threatening Checkmate and G2 and now
Queen 38 with check alireza goes back
and Wesley goes back Queen to F6 alireza
goes back again there's just no good
move here and now Wesley realizes that
okay he could just flag alireza that's
also allowed but uh Wesley is is a true
gentleman and he goes for the actual
winning move so Queen 38th check Queen
to E8 now Queen captures and C7 and now
if you repeat it doesn't matter then
another check lands and then the D6 Pawn
uh hangs with the check and then you're
just up too much material and you can
just even trade Queens to win this uh so
here Rook captures and G2 check was
played King captures and now Knight
captures uh the problem with Queen T to
check of course is that after King to G3
no more checks and Checkmate is being
threatened so you can't really do
anything with the queen there so alireza
had to try Knight captures on F4 check
we have King to G3 and now Knight to H5
check King to F3 and it was in this
position on move 40 that alireza firusha
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here Wesley is
completely winning and for those of you
who enjoyed when I finish the game the
easiest way would be
um if you even manage to find the move
for black because there just aren't any
you could play something like King Jade
now comes root captures on D6 of course
now you're threatening to win the queen
and if you move the king then you just
get this Checkmate Rook captures on H6
you're King G8 now you play any move uh
and the black is in the total two swung
and after you make one move 97 checking
f8 for example and The Rook to h8 will
be Checkmate it's only one of the nicer
ones but like I said absolutely
everything wins here so yeah it was a
pretty pretty crazy stuff uh here that
uh after you know uh already comes back
from a five a five point uh uh deficit
that then he equalizes then one plus one
it gets equal uh for four and a half
points each and then another two points
each in the tie breaks and then I mean
you've seen the game uh Wesley is just
so strong in the Joker piano and he
found like even after blundering that
pawn he found the crucial move and like
I said uh rarely will you will you win a
game in the Joker piano without playing
Pawn to B4 he didn't play it on the
fourth move but he found it now when it
mattered so there you have it and here
are the uh who who is playing who so
there you have it uh uh Wesley so is the
first semi-finalist he will he's waiting
for uh the winner uh between Carlson and
his opponent uh uh I don't know for some
reason nepo and darjun still haven't
played or they have played but they
haven't updated the table then we have
nihal mvl uh who will be playing in the
quarter finals and Nakamura will be
facing carwana in the corner finals uh
so yeah that's the game and a little bit
of info about the match hope you guys
enjoyed it it's only the last game if
you have a chance to watch the entire
match it was a really really awesome so
you know if you manage the time maybe
when you're at work so you know you
don't waste time uh so yeah that's the
game hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank Duncan wine called egbertian cheer
Horn olavoy uh Adam Decker the loneliest
single guy in the world and Giuseppe
Albano for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check to all my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on you one of the
suggestions and whatever happens in the
Chess World so thank you all I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day